let me ask you about your now friend can
we go as far as it says friend uh in
asabu and Hector massager
what's the uh what's what's the story
what's your long story with him can you
tell me about what is lawsek
who is Sabu
and who's Anonymous what is anonymous
where's the right place to start that
story probably anonymous anonymous is a
was a d it still is I guess a
decentralized organization uh they call
themselves headless but once you look
into them a little ways they're not
really headless
um the the the power struggle comes with
whoever has a hacking ability
um that might be you're a good hacker or
you have a giant bot net used for DDOS
um so so you're gonna wield more power
if you can control where it goes
Anonymous started doing their like
hacktivism stuff in 2010 or so
um the word hack was in the media all
the time then
um and then right around then there was
a federal contractor named HB Gary
Federal the the CEO is Aaron Barr and
Aaron Barr said he was going to come out
and de-anonymize anonymous he's gonna
come out and talk at blackhead or Defcon
or one of those and say you know who
they are he figured it out or so he
could figure it out by based on uh you
know when people are online when people
are in IRC when tweets came out it was
there was no scientific proof behind it
or anything so he's just gonna falsely
name people that were that were in
anonymous
so Anonymous went on the attack they
went and hacked an ATV HP Area Federal
and they turned his life upside down
they took over his Twitter account and
all that stuff
um pretty quickly so I have very mixed
feelings about all of this okay I get
like part of me
admires the positive side of the
hacktivism okay
is there no room for admiration there of
the [ __ ] you to the man not at the time
again it was the violation the 18 USC 10
30. so it was my job that's what I you
know so at the time no in retrospect
sure
yeah but uh uh what was the philosophy
of the hacktivism was it the
philosophically were they at least
expressing it for the good of humanity
or no they outwardly said that they were
going to go after people that they
thought were corrupt so they were
judging jury on corruption they would go
after it
once you get on inside and realize what
they were doing they were going after
people that they had an opportunity to
go after
um so maybe someone had a zero day and
then they searched for servers running
that zero day and then from there let's
find a Target I mean one time they went
after a toilet paper company I still
don't understand what that toilet paper
company did but it was an opportunity to
make a splash is there some somewhere
for the joke for the lulls
it developed into that so I I think the
hacktivism and the anonymous stuff
wasn't so much for the lulls
um but from that HP gear Federal hack
then there were six guys that worked
well together and they formed a crew a
hacking crew and they kind of split off
into their own private channels and that
was lol SEC or laughing at your security
was their motto
so that's
l-u-l-z-s-e-c lol's SEC of course it is
sex and uh
who founded that organization so Kayla
and Sabu were the hackers of the group
and so they really did all the work on
HP Gary so they're these are code names
yeah they're online names they're
they're Knicks
um and so you know they they and they
that's all they knew each other as you
know they talk to us as those names
um and they worked well together and so
they formed a hacking crew and that's
when they started the the at first they
didn't name it this was the 50 days of
LOLs where they would just release
major major breaches
um and it stirred up the media I mean it
put hacking in on in the media every day
uh they had 400 or 500 000 Twitter
followers
um you know and it was kind of
interesting
um but then they started swinging at the
Beehive and they they took out some FBI
Affiliated sites uh and then they
started uh [ __ ] FBI Fridays uh where
every every Friday they would release
something and we waited it for baited
breath I mean they had us Hook Line and
Sinker pissed uh we were waiting to see
what was going to be dropped every
Friday here it was
it's a little embarrassing looking back
on it now and this is in the early 2010s
yeah this was 2010 2011 around there so
I actually Linger on
um
Anonymous what do you still understand
what the heck is anonymous it's just a
place where you hang out I mean it's
just to start on 4chan with Han and then
it's really just anyone you could be an
anonymous right now if you wanted to
just you're in there hanging out in the
channel now you're probably not going to
get much cred until you work your way up
and prove who you are someone vouches
for you uh but anybody can be an
anonymous and if you can leave Anonymous
what's the leadership of anonymous do
you have a sense that there is a
leadership there's a power play you know
it's not someone that you know that says
this is what we're doing all we're doing
I love the
the philosophical and the technical
aspect of all of this but I think there
is a slippery slope to where for the
laws you can actually
really hurt people
that's that's the terrifying thing when
you attach
I'm actually really terrified of the
power of the lull
it's the fun thing somehow becomes a
slippery slope I haven't quite
understood the Dynamics of that but even
in myself if you just have fun with a
thing you lose track of the ethical
grounding of the thing and so like it
feels like hacking for fun can just turn
it like literally lead to nuclear war
like literally destabilize the yada yada
yada nuclear war I could see it yeah
and so I've been more careful with the
lull uh uh I I'm very yeah I've been
more careful about that and I wonder
about it because an internet speak
somehow ethics can be put aside
uh through the slippery slope of
language
I don't know everything becomes a joke
if everything's a joke then everything
is allowed and everything's allowed then
you don't have a sense of what is right
and wrong you lose sense of what is
right and wrong you still have victims I
mean you're laughing at someone
someone's the butt of this joke
you know whether it's major corporations
or the individuals I mean some of the
stuff they did was just you know
releasing people's pii and their
personal identifying information and
stuff like that I mean is it a big deal
I don't know maybe maybe not but you
know if you could choose to not have
your information put out there probably
wouldn't
we do have a sense of what Anonymous is
today is it has it ever been one stable
organization or is it a collection of
hackers that kind of emerge
for particular tasks for particular uh
like a hacktivism task and that kind of
stuff it's a collection of people that
has some hackers in it there's not a lot
of big hackers in it I mean there are
some that have come bounce in and bounce
out even back then there was probably
just as many reporters in it people the
media in it with uh than hackers at the
time just trying to get the inside scoop
on things
you know some giving the inside scoop
you know we arrested a reporter they
gave over the uh username and password
to his newspaper and uh you know just so
he could break the story
he trusted him